the current situation demands that we
reinforce the deterrent and defensive
posture on nato's eastern flank
president biden has been clear
that the united states will respond to
the growing threat to europe's security
and stability
our commitment to nato article 5
and collective defense remains ironclad
as part of this commitment and to be
prepared for a range of contingencies
the united states will soon move
additional forces to romania
poland and germany
i want to be very clear about something
these are not permanent moves
they are moves designed to respond to
the current security environment
moreover
these forces are not going to fight in
ukraine
they are going to ensure the robust
defense
of our nato allies
1 000 soldiers that are currently based
in germany will reposition to romania in
the coming days this is a striker
squadron
a mounted cavalry unit that's designed
to deploy in short order
and to move quickly once in place
and they will augment the some
900 us forces that are currently in
romania
now this force is designed to deter
aggression and enhance our defensive
capabilities in front line allied states
and we expect them as i said to move in
coming days
and again i want to stress
that this move is coming at the express
invitation of the romanian government
address
we are moving uh an additional force of
about approximately 2 000 troops from
the united states to europe in the next
few days
the 82nd airborne division is deploying
components of an infantry brigade combat
team and key enablers to poland and the
18th airborne corps is moving a joint
task force capable headquarters to
germany both of them as you know are
based in fort bragg north carolina
collectively
this force is trained and equipped for a
variety of missions to deter aggression
and to reassure
and to defend our allies
not surprisingly we work very closely
with our polish and german allies to set
the stage for these movements and we
absolutely appreciate their support
all of these forces are separate and in
addition to the 8 500 personnel in the
united states on heightened alert
posture that i announced last week those
8 500 are not currently being deployed
but remain ready to move if called
for the nato response force or as needed
for other contingencies as directed by
the secretary or by president biden
now as the secretary said friday
we do not know if russia has made a
final decision
to further invade ukraine
but it clearly has that capability
the department of defense will continue
to support diplomatic efforts led by the
white house and the state department to
press for resolution we do not believe
conflict is inevitable
the united states in lockstep with our
allies and partners has offered russia a
path to de-escalate
but we will take all prudent measures to
assure our own security and that of our
allies
i would not read this as a decision made
based on any events over the last 48
hours or couple of days we've been in
discussion and under discussion with our
partners and allies in the region where
these troops are going uh for several
weeks now you know the president has
been clear uh since the beginning of uh
the escalation uh and the in the
building of troops at the border and
been directly clear with president putin
as he was in early december if russia
stays on an escalatory path which they
clearly have we will make forced posture
adjustments to deter and defend against
any aggression this is not uh troops
that will go into ukraine they're not
fighting in ukraine these this is us
this is the united states abiding by our
commitments under article 5 to support
reassure our partners in the region we
know that
that
that he also bristles uh at nato uh
about nato uh and uh he has made no
secret of that um
we are making it clear uh that we're
gonna be prepared to defend our nato
allies if it comes to that hopefully it
won't come to that nobody wants to see
as i said conflict's not inevitable
there's no reason for uh there
for there to be armed conflict in
ukraine or anywhere else on the european
continent and mr putin can go a long way
to serving that end
by taking seriously the proposals that
we have put forward diplomatically and
by de-escalating through moving some of
those troops away